in overseas news an attempt to lift the
ban on gays serving in the british armed
forces has been defeated in parliament
this raises a difficult legal question
how do you exactly tell if a british guy
is gay
but you guys are a great crowd some
people get so offended by these jokes
the gay joke the puerto rican joke i got
yelled at by a guy recently on the show
this guy comes up and goes hey buddy i'm
gay
and puerto rican all right
i don't appreciate those jokes you know
how hard my life is
i was like whoa take it easy how hard
your life is dude
you have the most parades
schmitz the jenny jones guest who killed
his secret gay admirer because of his
fear and hatred of homosexuality has
been sentenced to 25 years in prison
well i guess that plan backfired huh
stereotypical gay guy here's the thing
right
it's not cool right to make fun of
stereotypical gay people but there are
some gay guys who talk like that there
are gay guys who wear shorts that are
really tight and then those sleeve
shirts can go you're an [ __ ]
and those guys are silly
and they should be laughed at
not all of you to say hey all gay people
act like this is wrong but to point out
that a gay guy that acts like that is
funny
it's just [ __ ] true they're hilarious
hello
there aren't gay guys who act like that
and they're [ __ ] ridiculous
of course they are
it's like when you see a black guy there
are black guys who go [ __ ]
oh yeah that shit's funny it's weird to
talk like that
it's weird
you know and it's not wrong to make fun
of jews that they're all chewy you know
i'm sticking here in the stereotype that
jews love money it's just not true i
have his friend who's jewish if i tried
to give him a dollar
this week phoenix sons president rick
welts told the new york times that he is
gay rumors have swirled around welts
ever since he debuted his idea for the
sun's new uniforms
no uniforms
[Applause]
in a heartwarming gesture the entire
son's team rallied around their
president and blew him
[Applause]
is that your girlfriend that's your wife
no fiance or wife wife wife wife how
long you guys been married
year and a half that's what's up
is that adorable what
yo i don't understand that reaction
why'd you say oh
what was that
oh we got one single ass [ __ ] over
there
you suck
you hear what she said
y'all missed it she was like i almost
threw up you know what
why are you hating on love with your
lonely ass
you're here by yourself be honest
everybody's uh be honest
not at all you with me with a guy
is that does she have a dick
it's a man or a woman
it's a man your best friend yo he
friends on you that's [ __ ] up huh
you know how you get out of the friend
zone it's real easy you just go like
this
[Applause]
one way in one way out baby
[Applause]
look at him he's like hey you got a
point my man got a point
we've got some wisdom on stage some
wisdom
you guys never hooked up at all
you feel like throwing up a lot
why would you say that he's right next
to you
because
oh you play for the other team oh you're
a lesbian
oh all right i see what you're saying
sir are you straight
you're straight okay that's what i
actually think we need to team up a
little bit more
straight people are lesbians i mean that
[ __ ]
yeah cause y'all likey and [ __ ]
you know
don't you wish you could just hire a
lesbian to tap in when your girl wants a
[ __ ] like
like you just go and start it up and
then the second your girl closes her
eyes you're like yo gertrude get in here
handle that [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in there gonna
she dive in first like sonic
[ __ ] swan dive into the [ __ ]
right when she's about to come like [ __ ]
out of here yo come on
so you guys are best friends have you
ever been with a dude
you have how that should go
you weren't into it why because you
didn't come
yo i'ma tell you a little secret
most women don't you know what i mean
it's uh
you might still be straight [ __ ] i'm
just telling you this
i'm just saying it like
[Applause]
it's like trying pizza once and be like
i don't like all pizza no you don't like
that slice
well you okay but like you don't hate
okay
cause i'm trying to understand it this
is what i'm trying to understand like
you like the feeling of a dick
right
you must
hold on i got this
i got the [ __ ] aclu in the back
this is hate speech can you please
like a dildo looks like a dick not a
[ __ ]
you don't use so you get a pocket [ __ ]
and just rub it up against her [ __ ]
like if you really love [ __ ] you would
get a pocket [ __ ] and just scissor that
[ __ ] all night long
yo that's how you know if you're a
four-star lesbian if you got pocket
[ __ ] at the crib bro
you've got a fleshlight just like
tell me that don't make a little sense
yo
[Music]
yeah my friend's a gay guy he's obsessed
with straight dudes that's like his
thing he's like i love flipping a hetero
he's like you know how hard that is you
know hard to go out there every night
see a bunch of people you want to have
sex with who don't have sex with you i
was like that's exactly what it's like
being a straight guy
what the hell are you talking about i
would argue it's just as hard for me to
sleep with a woman is for you to flip a
hetero he was like no no no you got to
take him out for hours convince him yeah
yeah same here
he's like no no even if you do pull it
off which is like a miracle they feel
horrible after yeah yeah same thing
we went back and forth for hours arguing
about this all night back and forth
eventually i woke up at his place
i am not saying that to say
that trans
women
aren't women
i am just saying
that those [ __ ] that they got
you know what i mean
i'm not saying it's not [ __ ] but that's
like
beyond [ __ ] or impossible [ __ ]
tastes like [ __ ] that's not quite what
it is is it
it's not blood that's beet juice
[Applause]
beginning in march dc comics will change
superman's traditional red and blue
costume to a new form-fitting bodysuit
the problem with the old costume not gay
enough
[Music]
what the hell's going on in the country
do you do you remember on my podcast you
railed for about 30 hilarious minutes
against marriage like the most
persuasive
never get married it's a racket they're
gonna take half your [ __ ]
that lie but at this point no that's
true and i maintain that
it is
an absolutely
insane thing to do yes gay or straight
they just have no idea what they're
walking into i can't
wait i don't i don't wish this on
anybody when but when the gay divorces
start coming in they're they're really
going to step back i think being like
what the hell did were we wishing for
here
you know
i could have sent him a card on his
deathbed i didn't
really
that was a big thing i can't go and say
goodbye when they're dying but uh that's
if you make it
but it's literally like as far as
marriage is working that's like the
sperm making it to the egg
yeah you're saying dude it's facts
most of them don't work
then you gotta start all over again just
bust it you know yeah
i don't know how it's gonna work
with because it usually sides for the
women but when you got two dudes like
how's how is that going to work out
right
you know what i'm saying i guess it
works out for whoever's making more
money
this is classic like how i talk on the
podcast i just get into it and then i'll
be like oh hey i'm a [ __ ] and i didn't
read up on this
yeah how was that gonna work out well
guys that's gonna work out
the gang dude the gay dude who's not
doing [ __ ]
is gonna get all the stuff and be like
oh i'm used to a certain lifestyle
right
and then the gay guy who's killing it
he's gonna go back to the studio
apartment calling it right now calling
it right now
it's gonna be horrible so you're gonna
be great it'll bring straights and gays
closer together just start like a
divorce
bar like all people welcome
and just compare notes like what's more
horrific
of
a bitter ex dude or a bitter ex-woman
yeah when they wrote that hell hath no
fury like a woman's corn there weren't
as many public gay relationships so
maybe maybe that's real bad too yeah but
they didn't have the right to try
not being married they didn't have a
legal contract right so i think what
that when they broke up was probably
whoever was stronger
you know they just sort of wrestled
stuff
you guys are taking this really
seriously
does he really think that's how gay
people break up i'm just messing around
he introduced me as a comedian
right
am i gonna have to go on split screen
with a blogger
comedy can it go too far